um who else wants to chime in on the on
the topic of the importance of frame
when it comes to advanced dating
anybody got any experiences or jumping
or stories yeah go ahead
um so i'm a little bit different from
some of the other guys here uh i'm on
marriage who's that is that steve
talking um
yeah that's me steve okay sorry go ahead
yeah so again i'm 40. uh my marriage
number two
kind of what brought me into the space
was the concept of frame and then later
on the concept of vetting um so first
marriage fell apart a hundred percent it
was one of those
digitization through a thousand
concessions and i realized that years in
last marriage lasted a little over a
decade
i realized it several years in um it
made the attempt to kind of re-establish
frame at that point it was too late so
things fell apart with the spinning
plates
i was for a few years 100
cold approach no dating apps no nothing
it was all based on repeat encounters
with with girls
and building conversation naturally that
way and
during that i had a particular girl that
kept rising to the top of always having
a good time with her um
definitely the easiest to get along with
and from my perspective
the transition to ltr was something i
wanted um for my for my own reasons one
my work is kind of a pain in the ass and
two i i personally find at this point
the game is spinning plates to be
somewhat exhausting uh so i realized a
little bit of a divergence there from
the rest of the crowd that's cool but
for me uh thinking about stability for
my kids long-term prospects of of having
a partner that i'm building life with
ltr was right for me um and one of the
things so early on she kind of made the
made the ask of hey you know where's
this going i said well listen i have a
great time with you
what kind of commitment are you looking
for and what kind of commitment are you
providing
so she kind of laid it out i want this
to be exclusive
i said okay
um and a few weeks in probably three or
four
nothing had changed on her but i had cut
everything off gone exclusive so i
called her on it i said hey look
we had this conversation you know x
number of weeks ago things have changed
on my end and the following manners one
two three they have not changed on your
end i said so
i've overly emotionally invested you're
taking the driver's seat here i said i'm
done
um had a great time but this isn't
working for me she says okay calls me
back the next day
says hey look i thought a lot about what
you said um
you know i uh i really want this to work
out i thought kind of about the items
you laid out here's my plan would you
give me another 30 days to turn this
around i said let's meet for dinner
so i met i said unlock your phone set it
on the table
and she does it and i said i'm going to
go through it i want to see all your
social media i want to see all your
messages and she said okay but why i
said what i want to know is
are you flaking on me right now because
the story about your work is legit or
are you flaking on me because you're
you're seeking attention and you're
looking for me to fulfill something
where you remain in control and she said
go ahead
went through facebook went through
instagram went through her messages went
through the whole phone and it turned
out it was legit um three years later
we're still going strong um so what i
stress to guys that are looking to
transition from placement into ltr
is one that bet her behavior better
behavior with co-workers better behavior
with friends better behavior on social
media
that her family what's her interaction
with her family like and then back up
the things that she says she's going to
do with the actions that follow and if
those things don't jive you need to run
um so uh steve
question for you you mentioned that um
she gave you the word we stand talk and
then wanted to be
monogamous with you which you agreed to
but it didn't sound like she was holding
up her end of the bargain during that
time
no she stayed exclusive uh where she
lacked was
um time commitment energy commitment
okay personal emotional investment into
the relationship that i'm i expect
because in my mind that kind of plays
into genuine burning desire okay if you
have genuine burning desire if you do
consider me to be that best option you
know i'm not going to be an afterthought
in your day-to-day life
uh i'm i'm curious about the other guys
on the panel right now like what are
your thoughts are on a
um you know pop uh phone
scavenging hunt
um i'll give you my experience i am
i'm not gonna ask i think there's
you know i can certainly see that some
guys that it makes a lot of sense it's
something they want to do but i think
there's so many other behaviors
that you'll be able to pick up on where
it's like
it's either well it's probably the best
way to put it you'll see another
behavior
uh
where you're like okay this is not
you're
we're clearly two different places here
you know i think where it really comes
into play is you know is this going to
turn into a long-term relationship or
not this is just some
guy you're seeing it's like who cares um
but if this has turned into something
more serious
and i agree with steve 100
um
checking those references if you will
will tell you everything um
but uh i i don't want to go through some
chicks bone to be honest
i'll tell you guys why i think it's
actually not a bad idea and i agree with
steve because
you know she ended up giving him the
where do we stand talk and he's like
okay fine i'll abandon my sexual
strategy of unlimited access to
unlimited women all right but then the
spidey senses started to tangle and he
wanted to verify for himself and i don't
think that there's anything wrong with
that especially given the conversation
that he had and what his relationship
goals are
right
i'm in the same i'm in the same boat um
you know with my
with my current ltr it's not like
you know every freaking second but once
a month once every two months if i just
happen to see your phone i'll pick it up
scroll through the text
and see if there's anything weird there
because she she's a she does she does
outside sales
and ninety percent of our clientele are
men
and i know i know what the deal is so
you know yeah and i just and it's not
malicious or anything like that it's
just like
i'm i'm gonna make sure
that everything is straight and if it's
not straight it's gonna be confronted
immediately this is the deal she knows
that
i agree with that and in my opinion
you know i don't
i don't want to to promote an ongoing
culture of mistrust
and kind of the way i couched it in the
moment is
is you know i'm asking for this
because of the following criteria you
and i agreed to there's behaviors x y z
that don't align to this you're telling
me you want something different that you
want a second chance i'm receptive to
that but i need some currency and coin
in the realm to know that what you're
asking for is legitimate and that i'm
not just getting strong along
um and so when she agreed to that i
think that was a it was
it showed heavy investment on her part
that hey i'm willing to open the books
to this guy
i'm willing to show him you know the the
records he's looking for to get that in
um you know because again if if
hypergamy's not satisfied or it's
satisfied only in that moment you are
setting yourself up for failure
um but when sh in my opinion in that
moment she's willing to open the books
and willing to talk about everything um
that gives me that you know as you
mentioned rich that extra reassurance
okay hey i am the program this best
option here she is being genuine in the
things she's talking about the story
she's telling me about the work life is
is is genuine and there's not the the
social media attention seeking behavior
that i think wrecks a lot of women in
relationship
right on um
well i don't mean to cut everybody off
and jumping forward good mother yeah
well because look like
i'm curious the rest of the guys
especially jaren's thoughts or whoever
but this idea of
getting
somebody being congruent with you
yeah
uh well i need to see your phone because
i need to do this i need to do that and
this idea of logically listing out the
reasons why as opposed to just
you know you you decided you were going
to commit and you were going to say okay
we're going to be monogamous but you
don't see the behavior is changing in a
positive way so
you know in my opinion the best way to
to change that behavior is to give less
of your attention less of your time i
mean it worked out in the end it seems
like and she seemed open for it and
that's great but i mean i'm curious what
other guys think when it's it
in retrospect you know was that the way
that you guys would handle it or or is
it just like okay like i'm gonna i'm
going to go back to what i was doing
because i'm not getting the results that
i was promised
well it worked because it didn't work
because of any logical explanation when
it comes to checking it because
it worked because it gave her a huge
emotional response
that's the reason it worked good there's
no there's no explaining anything
logically it made her have an emotional
response it made her feel like oh she
gave her an oh moment and because
she had that emotional response that's
what connected her to him it wasn't any
logic at all all right derek what hey
go ahead derek i wanna hear your opinion
um
so i'm i'm pretty split on the whole
issue but uh
my whole
my whole thing with frame is you gotta
know who you are before you before you
invite anyone else into it
um
you know i just moved to this new city
on the other side of the country in the
u.s
and i'm here for a limited time
i travel a lot for work so
you know when i'm in town i want to have
a good time
and uh i've been seeing this check a
little bit younger than me for a couple
months
she said she sat me down had the uh what
are we talk
and i was just like look i'm here to
have a good time and you know i think
you're wonderful i've had a blast with
you but i'm not looking for anything too
serious right now
and uh lo and behold she was like all
right
not not feeling this right now wanted
something how old was she
she
20 she's 22.
okay with me too at the time
all right uh didn't talk to her for
three months you know kind of felt bad
that it ended so abruptly but then lo
and behold you know about a month ago at
two o'clock in the morning i get a
drunken booty call and now she's coming
over in two hours so
you know you just gotta hold your frame
and
realize that they're going to try to you
know bring you into their society
yeah it's um
yeah it's a really good point because i
mean like you made your
intentions and your expectations clear
she said that didn't work for her so she
bounced but she decided to come back
when it worked out for her though right
i mean you know you then became a better
option or an acceptable option
a few months later
you